okay here will come to order Walt
Whitman wrote that to do the labor of a
prudent watchman who prevents outrage is
one of the proper duties of a government
our witnesses today are the sort of
folks from Walt Walt Whitman had in mind
their hard work and aggressive oversight
has gone a long way toward keeping the
tarp program relatively efficient and
honest that's no small task when you
look at the size of tarp and the speed
at which it was set up tarp remains one
of the largest and most complex programs
that the federal government has ever
created and that means that it's all the
more important that we have the three
oversight teams before us today I worked
hard to create the office of the special
inspector general for the time back when
Congress was developing the program so
I'm especially pleased to welcome mr.
barofsky back to the committee today so
far that special IG has done a great job
you're providing critical transparency
to the program developing important
studies on specific aspects of the
program and even busting bad guys I
graduate mr. borovsky and his team for
the work on the leaf arcas case mr.
Farkas was the head of a private
mortgage lending company who's arrested
on jun 15 and charged with a 1.9 billion
dollar fraud you know there's were
charged with scheming to steal 550
million dollars of tarp money that
scheme was stopped dead in its tracks
and the special IG is conducted
independent analysis that has brought
critical transparency to the tarp
program an examples especially jeez
report on Monday in that report he
concluded that the administration's auto
task force pressure GM and Chrysler to
close many auto dealerships without
ethically considering job losses this
dudes is quite troubling in Montana and
across the country our auto dealers are
local small businesses and often the
heart of the community I'm disappointed
to learn that many of the decisions by
the auto task force made without full
consider
of the effects on these communities
fortunately some auto dealers have
successfully restored their franchises
but many others have closed or have been
forced to adjust to losing a franchise
agreement during the most significant
economic downturn since the Great
Depression Ostrovsky applaud you for
bringing issues such as this to the
tension of Congress in the American
taxpayers with Elizabeth Warren of the
Congressional Oversight Panel can bring
us up to date on how small banks are
framed under the tarp program her most
recent report raises concerns but how
fast small banks be able to pay tart
back more than three-quarters of the
large banks receive tarp money have
already repaid the taxpayers by contrast
only ten percent of the small banks
received tarp funds have repaid their
money there's also interest in an update
on the AIG Goldman Sachs relationship
that you reported on earlier this year
oversight is sometimes a lonely job it
doesn't win Hume any popularity contests
we've all been pleased to witness the
perseverance of your three teams were
the best last year and a half since
Congress created tarp program in some
respects the end of the program is in
sight to just over the horizon the wall
street reform bill that we passed last
week bars any programs and initiatives
they will also caps disbursements at 475
billion dollars and the treasury
reported that the total amount repaid at
taxpayers for the government funds used
to bail out US companies has surpassed
for the first time the amount of tarps
outstanding debt losses from the tarp
program are still projected to be high
but the government will not see a 700
billion dollar loss for tarp as some
have said back in the fall 2008 year ago
the losses were projected to be 341
billion dollars instead current loss
estimates looked to be more in the range
of 100 billion dollars and some are
saying that figure could go lower
depending on repayment from AIG in the
auto companies the debate over the
necessity for tarp its
effect on the economy will continue I
note that our colleague Judd Gregg said
last week that quote tarp did what it
was supposed to do it basically saved
the financial system on Main Street to
end quote nellen blinder the former vice
chairman of the Federal Reserve said
tarp quote was a necessary evil to save
the economy think of it as collateral
damage in a successful war against
financial Armageddon end quote what we
do know today is that the hard work and
sacrifice of our three oversight teams
as given the American people a
relatively clean well run program I do
believe that I think it's your oversight
of you three then it was largely the
reason why there had not been
difficulties scandals problems so forth
because you worked very hard all three
of you to exercise you a very vigorous
oversight I think the American taxpayers
are very appreciative of that we are
grateful for your efforts we stand ready
to help you continue your good work as a
tarp program it comes to an end over
comes to an end and we hope that that
will be in the greater future I'm
Grassley yeah I associate myself with
the remarks at the prayer that the
Chairman just made on well complimenting
you on your oversight each of you we
have this 700 billion dollar program
been a focus of numerous audits hearings
and reports and at every stage each of
you has brought more transparency and
accountability to the activities of
Treasury in short you kept Treasury
honest a critical service with so much
taxpayers money at stake each of your
organization's have published numerous
reports on different aspects of tarp
just this morning Special Inspector
General published its seventh quarterly
report with tarp scheduled to expire
October third I look forward to hearing
each of you update the committee on your
activities mr. Barcia murph borovsky
your office released a report this week
describing the process by which the
administration forced
the administration forced GM and
Chrysler to a celery the closure of 2243
dealerships putting at risk as many as
100,000 jobs without first determining
that the pace and scope of the closures
was truly necessary while your report is
insightful unfortunately it comes too
late for many car dealer owners and
suppliers across the country that were
forced out of business for very little
reason it's frustrating to know that at
a time when small businesses are hurting
and we're facing record unemployment
this administration was pushing to shut
down these dealerships and your new
quarterly report contains a startling
observation that although tarp appears
to be winding down when non tarp aid is
included the amount of overall
government assistance actually grew
during the last 12 months last year you
estimated the total amount of taxpayers
money at risk through various programs
to be 3 trillion dollars your new
estimate is 3.7 trillion dollars 700
billion dollar increase and that's as
much as the original tarp program was
ever expected to be I also know that
your office has been actively
investigating excessive AIG executive
compensation payments that have been
largely ignored by the Treasury and I've
been continuing my inquiry into the
severance package received by a former
AIG executive it seems that the
executive received nearly three times
her salary and severance bonuses or
about one in four tenths million dollars
although she was terminated her
severance was increased and Treasury
could have stopped the payments but did
nothing mr. Chairman I have
documentation on this I'd like to put a
record for miss Warren bobs action last
month your congressional oversight panel
reported on AIG bailouts and we learned
that among the ultimate beneficiaries of
the tax funded AIG bailout was not just
a aiji's counterparties Goldman Sachs
but also Goldman's counterparties it is
estimated that Goldman's counterparties
may have benefited from the taxpayer
bailout of AIG by avoiding
as much as 11 billion dollars in losses
and yet incredibly we don't know who
those County parties are Goldman has
refused to provide your panel with names
of those companies and mr. Chairman I
have a summary that I'd also like to
include in the record as I asked just
ask you to on another matter objection
the Congressional Oversight Panel also
issued a report this week about tarps
capital purchase program it details how
Treasury seems to have treated the
nation's largest banks much more
favorably than it treated nation smaller
banks many of the smaller banks now are
struggling and their participation in
tarp has neither stabilize the financial
system nor increase lending activity
let's look at GL mr. Hillman's office
also released a report about AIG one
focus of the report is a status of a
aiji's attempt to repay its debt to the
American taxpayer over time the
government has exchanged much of AI G's
debt for stock meaning that the
government's ability to recoup the
billions advance to aid I G will depend
to a large degree on a aiji's ability to
sell its business assets as it
restructures the recent collapse of 35
billion dollar deal to sell an aig life
insurance subsidiary is an ominous sign
that the taxpayers not may not get back
their money or at least take a long time
one of the purposes of TARPA course was
to preserve homeownership and protect
home values Treasury announced the 50
billion dollar home affordable
modification program in march two
thousand nine and all three of the
watchdog's on the panel today have
issued reports on the program's progress
and that's not good any progress hasn't
been good in a program that Treasury
said would result in three to four
million modifications there have been
only three hundred forty thousand
permanent in fact there have been four
hundred and thirty thousand failed trial
modifications meaning failed
modifications vastly outnumber
successful ones and just as I warned REE
defaults look like they will be
a real problem the debt to income ratio
for borrowers that have received a
mortgage modification is sixty-four
percent even after modification a level
that all that ensures high default rates
moreover Treasury still has not
established performance goals or
benchmarks for the program meaning that
there is no effective way for us to know
whether this 50 billion dollar program
is accomplishing intended purposes
that's not accountabilities that's not
transparent e and it's just more
taxpayers money flying out the window
American taxpayers invest entire program
is unprecedented and as good stewards
the taxpayers money it's essential that
we exercise the highest standard of
oversight as you present your findings
today panel I ask that you specifically
advised the committee each of you of any
areas in which your oversight is being
limited or constrained by lack of
cooperation from the administration the
treasure department or others and how
best I and this committee can help you
Thank You mr. terms thank you a senator
want to thank our witnesses and their
teams for their hard work own or
persuade this is roskie special
inspector general for the tarp program
second witness is Elizabeth Warren chair
of the Congressional Oversight Panel and
the third witness is Rick Hillman
managing director of the financial
markets community investment team the
general accountability thank you all the
hard work I mean you're working very
hard half American people and thank you
again urges summarize your statements
because they'll automatically be
included in the record Elizabeth Warren
as a commitment so we're going to try to
accommodate of that obligation there's
porn so watch you first begin mr. Ross
key and it will go down the line there
okay Thank You mr. chairman chairman
Bachus ranking member Grassley thank you
for giving us an opportunity to come
back it is a privilege and honor to
testify once again before this committee
to release our most recent quarterly
report and I do want to thank thank you
and this committee for
your tremendous leadership in support of
our office our ability to accomplish
what we do derives directly from the
support of this committee and I'm happy
to report senator grassley that we have
we don't have haven't had any issues or
problems getting information in large
part because I think those that we deal
with know that this committee is
standing squarely behind us and that the
repercussions would be severe in our
quarterly report we give an update on on
this previous quarter and it's been a
noteworthy one as the chairman and the
ranking member have noted for both tarp
and forsake tarp for tarp as a chairman
noted more money is back than is
currently outstanding the loss
projections are going down and with
dodd-frank the cap is getting smaller
for sigtarp as the chairman noted I
think we've demonstrated this quarter
that robust proactive law enforcement is
an important part in a vital part of any
oversight program in this case the
chairman described our charges against
Lee Farkas that case was initiated in
connection with an application for tarp
funds from Colonial Bank which was
affiliated with mr. Farkas and received
conditional approval from Treasury for
553 million dollars in taxpayer funds
and through the hard work of cig tarps
agents and our law enforcement partners
we made sure that money didn't go out
the door that that money didn't get
poured into the gaping abyss of fraud
that was colonial bank and as a result
we've assured that this agency sigtarp
will have paid for itself over the
course of its life by those savings
alone as the ranking member noted in our
quarterly report we provided an update
on what we had done last summer at the
request of the Chairman last time I
testified before this committee of the
50 or so programs in addition to tarp
that address the scope of the financial
crisis the government's response and
support to financial institutions and
financial markets and in our report we
we summarize each of those 50 programs
and we provide numbers three key numbers
for each one the total amount or maximum
amount that was pledged or committed by
the federal government by the agency
that are explicitly or implicitly for
each of those programs the high-water
mark the maximum amount of money that
was out the door either in guarantee
or explicit expenditure at any one
period given a time and what the current
outstanding is as of june thirtieth of
this year and as the ranking member
noted when we compared that number to
the same number a year ago we found that
notwithstanding the reduction in tarp
and a lot of the liquidity programs of
the Federal Reserve the increases in
other programs designed to help the
housing markets and the financial
institutions that participate in them
far outweigh that to the tune of the
current amount of 3.7 trillion dollars
seven hundred billion dollars more than
the 303 trillion balance last year
finally our report we go over our
previous audits and outstanding
recommendations and including the one
mentioned by the ranking member one of
the greatest failures and transparency
and accountability in the current
program and that's Treasury's refusal to
identify meaningful benchmarks goals and
expectations for the mortgage
modification program it's a simple
recommendation that we made the treasury
put forth how many people it truly
expects to help stay in their houses
through permanent modifications it's a
recommendation that all three of us on
this panel have made to Treasury and
that Treasury has ignored this failure
to adopt this recommendation avails to
recognize the basic tenants of good
government program clear goals clear
expectations and clear description of
performance against those benchmarks its
failure to do so has essentially result
in the nation's taxpayers having to
shoulder an additional up to 50 billion
dollars in national debt without being
told how many people it's expected are
going to actually be helped by this
program stay in their homes how many
people are going to be helped in the
various alphabet soup of sub programs
and how the money is going to be spent
to achieve those benefits Treasury's
continued indications that this is a
successful program without identifying
these goals and benchmarks is simply not
credible and I fear that the growing
public suspicion that this program is an
outright failure will continue unless
and until Treasury adopts this
recommendation and comes clean with what
its goals and expectations are mr.
chairman ranking member members the
committee again I can't thank you enough
for your continued support of our office
of all of our efforts and I look forward
to answering any questions you may have
about the quarterly report about our
audit that we issued earlier this week
on the auto dealership terminations or
any other subject thank you thank you
thank you for asking very much miss
Warren you're next Thank you Thank You
chairman Baucus ranking member Grassley
and and committee I want to start with a
reminder that I must always I am the
chair of a bipartisan five-member panel
so while I will do my best to summarize
the work of the Congressional Oversight
Panel any additional sentences are my
own and my my colleagues may have
different different views different
nuances that they would bring two things
so so I want to make that disclaimer
since we last met before this committee
much has changed in the financial
markets and in tarp a year ago our
country was in the midst of what seemed
to be a deepening financial crisis on
the edge of economic collapse it is easy
now to forget the panic that gripped the
markets in the fall of two thousand
eight a very real threat that it would
spread to the broader economy
devastating families small businesses
and communities tarp has had a profound
effect as part of a coordinated
government response to bring our economy
back from the brink of collapse and
everything I say and the work we do an
oversight is in that context I also want
to say at the beginning we raised issues
from our very first report which was in
December of 2008 about accountability
and transparency difficulties we were
having at the time with Treasury and and
what we thought we brought to to
oversight by trying to bring these
issues forward after we met with this
committee of things changed
substantially and so I come here in part
on behalf of the Congressional Oversight
Panel to thank this committee for your
ongoing support I recall in particular a
conversation in which mr. Grassley said
if there's anything you can't get
sir Warren you let me know in the two of
us we'll walk over to Treasury and see
if we can if we can find what we need
senator baucus your office has been
enormously helpful that has made a real
difference in what has happened in our
oversight efforts we've been tough on
Treasury up but there really has been a
great deal more transparency of great
deal more openness with Treasury about
the information we made our oversight
panel has been in effect for 19 months
we have issued 21 monthly reports and
two special reports we've hit the range
from dollars and cents reports on the
value of bank warrants the Treasury was
selling under the capital purchase
program to review to a review of the
government's investment in specific
companies such as GM Chrysler AIG and
GMAC all of the reports along with
videos summaries backup documents are
available online at kop senate.gov we we
are we are part of the the senate
website and and glad for anyone to come
and see what we have I'm going to just
give a very brief summary of two of our
most recent programs the small banks
program you mentioned that Senator
Baucus in your opening remarks it's the
reminder that tarp money went to seven
hundred and seven banks the 17 largest
banks got eighty-one percent of the
money and they got it fast seventy-six
percent as you noted have now repaid and
our reporting substantial profits the
690 smaller banks had a very different
experience they got their money more
slowly only ten percent of repaid and
more worrisome fifteen percent have
already missed at least one of their
dividend repayments of the small bank
troubles are many there is a coming of
crisis in commercial real estate the
value of assets are held by these banks
will decline by the end of this year by
an estimated fifty percent
compared with the peak when many of
these loans were made and 2988 smaller
and intermediate sized banks have by
their own auditors admission deep
concentrations in commercial real estate
these banks also have limited access to
capital and if they don't find a way to
pull themselves out of the tarp program
in a few years their dividend will go up
from five percent to nine percent which
will put even further pressure on them
the reason I mentioned this report in
particular it's both our most recent but
it's also because the health of the
small banks is directly related to the
health of small businesses small banks
that are constrained small banks that
are under financial pressure are not
small banks that are able to support
small business lending so we we have a
problem that that gets in the way of
restarting the economy we have also
talked recently about AIG about the
small business credit crunch and the
foreclosure mitigation program I'm here
to answer questions as best I can on any
of our reports and to say again that the
Congressional Oversight Panel very much
appreciates the support we've gotten
from this committee thanks Warren mr.
Hillman you're our wrap up here chairman
Bachus ranking member Grassley members
of the committee I commend you for
holding this hearing today and I'm
pleased to be here to discuss our work
on the Troubled Asset Relief Program my
statement today draws primarily on seven
reports that we issued since October
2009 specifically this statement focuses
on the nature and the purpose of
activities that have been initiated
under tarp and their ongoing challenges
the process for making decisions related
to unwinding tarp programs and
indicators of the credit conditions and
markets targeted by tart programs
regarding our first objective Treasury
has initiated a number of programs under
tarp some of which have ended or are
being unwound others especially those
involving AIG the autumn o
LLL industry preserving home ownership
and encouraging lending to small
businesses may continue for some time
many participating institutions have
repaid the funds they received reducing
the federal government's exposure under
tarp since tarp was authorized Treasury
has dispersed 385 billion in loans and
equity investments as of jun 30th 2010
Treasury had received almost 25 billion
in dividends and interest payments and
warrant repurchases as well as more than
190 8 billion in repayments although
Treasury has received significant
repayments of the funds that it provided
to the financial institutions some
institutions and loans could still
result in substantial losses to the
government we have been monitoring talk
programs since their inception including
the financial condition of those
institutions that have received
significant assistance in particular
Chrysler and General Motors Company have
shown some indications of progress
towards returning to profitability such
as doing better than they had initially
projected in terms of revenue operating
earnings and cash flow however the
extent to which the federal government
will fully recoup its investment in the
auto industry is uncertain and the
companies face several challenges in the
coming years including returning to and
sustaining strong growth and
profitability since early 2009 we have
also been monitoring the status of the
federal assistance to AIG and its
financial condition using indicators we
developed in april 2010 reported that
our indicators showed that a aiji's
financial condition had remained
relatively stable largely due to the
federal assistance provided by the
Federal Reserve and Treasury but the
extent to which the federal government
will recoup its investment remains
uncertain and will not only depend on
the long-term health of AIG but also on
the company's success in selling
businesses as it restructures and other
market factors such as the performance
of the insurance companies and the
insurance sector and the credit credit
derivatives markets that are beyond the
control of AIG or the government
many of our reports have also
highlighted the challenges facing tarp
programs and we have made
recommendations to enhance the
transparency and accountability of
programs for example in a recent report
on the Home Affordable Modification
Program we stated that the program has
made limited progress and preserving
home ownership has suffered from
inconsistent program implementation and
continues to confront additional
challenges these include converting
trial modifications to permanent status
and ensuring program stability and
effective program management we reported
that while Treasury has taken some steps
to address these challenges it's
urgently needed for Treasury to finalize
and implement the various components of
the HAMP program and ensure the
transparency and accountability of these
efforts we will continue to monitor
these programs have and have ongoing
work on several facets of tarp including
those initiatives that have a small
business focus we have also received and
reviewed Treasury's framework for
deciding to extend tart beyond December
31 2009 and found that the process was
sufficient but could be strengthened for
similar decisions that will need to be
made in the future specifically we found
that the extent of coordination could be
enhanced and formalized between Treasury
and the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation and recommended that
Treasury formalized coordination with
FDIC for future decisions going forward
Treasury will continue to face decisions
in winding down programs and many of
these decisions will require interagency
coordination because tarp will be
unwinding concurrently with other
important regulatory interventions
decisions about the sequencing of the
exits from the program's will require
regulators to work closely together we
also noted that Treasury could
strengthen its in an analytical
framework for identifying clear
objectives for small business
initiatives and explaining how relevant
indicators motivated program decisions
regarding our last objective on the
indicators of credit conditions and
markets targeted by tark programs we
have noted in the past that some of our
anticipated effects of tarp on credit
markets and the economy have
materialized
and that some securitisation Marcus had
experienced a tentative recovery
indicators we have been monitoring
suggests that the credit markets have
been able to sustain their recovery
despite the winding down a key programs
initiated by the Federal Reserve
Treasury FDIC and others for example the
cost of credit and perceptions of risk
as measured by premiums over Treasury
securities have fallen in interbank
lending mortgage lending and corporate
debt markets further the volume of
credit as measured by new mortgage loans
and asset-backed securities has improved
since the first arc program
unfortunately by any measure
foreclosures and delinquency statistics
for residential housing remains well
above the historical averages despite
programs such as HAMP full recovery will
take some time given the build-up of
imbalances in the real estate fiscal and
household sectors over several years
finally because any new tarp activity
will be limited to home ownership
preservation and small business lending
programs we will also be continuing to
monitor indicators such as the
foreclosures and delinquency rates as
potential measures of the tuc program's
success mr. chairman and members of the
committee I appreciate the opportunity
to discuss these issues and be happy to
respond to any questions thank you very
much mr. Hellman say to my colleagues
sir that this Warren does have to leave
soon than 15 minutes so I'm going to
combine my questions to her and then
sochi can leave earlier so we then ask
other questions of other witnesses if
the mini doesn't mind if we don't use up
or five minutes in we can reserve the
time yes that's correct ok I miss Warren
I'm just like your thoughts on the on
the HAMP program why it's not working
very well mr. Barofsky suggests a better
benchmarks and more standards and so
forth front pages i recall Wall Street
Journal today's about housing markets
not doing too well so what's what's you
could just tell me what's your thoughts
of what's the advice for your small
banks many banks what
what needs to be done here so thank you
senator uh we've now written three
reports about the home ownership
mortgage foreclosure program and we said
in our first report which was 15 months
ago that the program was too small it
was too slow and it was not putting
enough people into permanent
modifications uh we said at the time we
urge Treasury to design a program that
could be ramped up quickly and get ahead
of the problem instead the position
we're in now is that we continued to
trail the problem 15 months into this
program for every one family that
appears to have made it to a permanent
modification that's likely to stabilize
that family in that home ten more have
been moved out through foreclosure uh
this is a program that's it's just it's
behind the curve y is not working well
it's too small it's too slow it looked
the program is based on the assumption
that we will get the servicers we will
pay the service as a bride to make a
deal that works between the homeowner
and the investor who's still holding the
paper and it has not worked well in many
cases the servicers can continue to make
more money if the family goes through
foreclosure it's just not a program
that's working for homeowners it's not a
programming in some cases that's working
for investors and most importantly it's
not a program that's working for the
economy overall zorroski your thoughts
on this program hey what needs to be
done and if you could amplify a little
more on your statement that we need more
benchmarks etc no I think that's
absolutely essential though that doesn't
ultimately get gent get to the heart of
why more people bring being helped the
numbers that Treasury has put out as
dismal as they seem when you dig deep
behind them in a way it gets almost
worse and what we've done in this
quarterly report for the first time and
what's not reported in treasuries number
is we actually disaggregate two aspects
of the HAMP program so part of it is
done by tarp funded modifications the
other part are done by Fannie and
Freddie and the 50 billion dollars of
tarp money is only for those tarp
modifications and it was originally
announced I think it was the basically
if you just go by the numbers 50 billion
for tarp 25 billion dollars for Fannie
and Freddie it was anticipated that
there be probably roughly two to one
ratio when you break out the most recent
numbers of about 390,000 permanent mods
only a hundred and sixty-five thousand
of those have come from tarp so if you
could look over the last 16 months
that's about 10,000 permanent mods a
month that's being funded through tarp
this is you know this is part of the
transparency that we try to bring by
breaking these numbers out so we can
really look at the tarp a piece of the
program the problems are as Professor
Warren has noted are all valid part of
it is we've made some recommendations on
vulnerability to Rida fault and to make
these programs more effective more
attractive one thing the Treasury has
done which i think is a step in the
right direction was to finally address
the issues of of principal reduction
which is I think a vital issue you know
all the predictions predictors of Rita
fall whether it's the Federal Reserve or
or you know Moody's or SP there's you
know we cite a bunch of studies all
point to negative equity as being a
major issue so they roll out some
significant programs but even those are
somewhat flawed what do you want the
Treasury to do well I think one thing
that we point out is that they should
make the principal reduction program
mandatory as it is now the servicers
basically get to pick and choose and
decide whether or not they want to you
know give homeowners to benefit of
principal reduction we've been in a
back-and-forth which is laid out in our
report we've asked them you know
preliminary what are your arguments why
are you doing this we found them to be
completely unconvincing and i think is
it's currently as planned to be will
could end up in random or and what would
you have Treasury do well i think that a
special inspector general barosky's in
the right direction we can't have a
program in which in effect we put
incentives on the table paid for by the
taxpayer to say please do the right
thing
here we have a crisis and the
consequences of not having cooperation
from the servicers are not just felt by
the investors who are harmed and by the
homeowners who are harmed their felt by
this entire economy we need a program
with far more urgency and and some real
teeth in it Thank You mr. Goslin I'm
just going to ask one question now a
professor Warren and if my colleagues
want to ask her we won't i won't use up
other people's time or keep her from
going in in your report on AIG bailout
you indicated that Goldman declined to
provide the panel with the names of the
entities that insured Goldman against
AIG bankruptcy you call these unnamed
insurers quote in direct beneficiaries
of the government's rescue and to quote
earlier I placed in the record a summary
of your attempts to get information from
Goldman that would explain who these
indirect beneficiaries were and as I
understand it about 11 billion dollars
of taxpayers money provided to AIG
ultimately benefited companies or
individuals who remain unknown soul to
you professor Warren can you explain why
Goldman won't provide this information
and why shouldn't the public know who
these ultimate beneficiaries of
taxpayers support actually are Thank You
senator uh I assume that the reason that
Goldman will not provide this as it does
not want the public to know let me make
it
the counterparties to the financial
transactions and also information about
who the alleged insurers were that is
when Goldman says we had no exposure in
this we were completely neutral it was
because they claimed to have bought in
effect insurance policies from third
parties obviously when AIG was rescued
they didn't have to pay off and we want
to know the identity of those parties
partly just to know where American
taxpayer dollars went but partly to
assess Goldman's claim if we can't see
who the parties are and can't see what
the transactions are we cannot evaluate
the credibility of their claim that they
had nothing at stake one way or the
other in the AIG bailout yeah mr.
chairman since the Congressional
Oversight Panel has been able unable to
get this information I'd like to suggest
to you that we consider the committee
asking for it and if Goldman Sachs
doesn't respond then we should consider
issuing a subpoena to require that the
information be provided well said I
think you make a good case that this and
as does Professor Warren at this
information it should be available so
what you tonight welcome i talked about
that and find a way to proceed so
somebody thank you this is a follow-up
to Chuck's question in late June the New
York Times reported on the latest AIG
outrage as part of an agreement to
cancel its derivatives deals and pay the
counterparties off at par AIG also
waived all legal rights to sue goldman
sachs merrill lynch and others for fraud
are other reasons on the mortgage-backed
securities they issued an aig issued
since that deal was partly funded with
tarp money
have any of you looked into this latest
giveaway to the big banks and the
taxpayers expense senator it is not part
of our AIG report because our a IG
report came out before those documents
but is it is it now being looked at we
we are looking into it senator yes we
are thank you if you are do you have any
idea how much money each of you expects
the taxpayer to lose on that tarp
investment oh that's a very difficult
question senator of the the consequence
of giving up one's right to pursue legal
remedies of when the other party to the
transaction may have made
misrepresentations may have otherwise
misbehaved oh it's very difficult to
assess and I don't I don't want to be in
the position of over-promising I don't I
won't I don't want you to either I mean
is there a reasonable chance of us
finding out without getting the papers
that Chuck and the chairman have talked
about to know exactly how much start
money is at risk I'm going to I'm going
to say this the other way but the
consequence of waiving the right to
pursue remedies so that AIG would have
at least potentially been able to sue
other parties and draw more funds back
into AIG which in turn could be used to
to repay the taxpayer that's the
transaction we're talking about I want
to be honest senator I'm not sure we
would ever be able to put a dollar
figure on that what we will try to do
what we can try to do is at least track
down where the waivers are and get some
assessment of what
what their value might have been but I i
we can't promise beyond that because
when the lawsuit doesn't go forward I
understand the data are never discovered
the the facts never come forward to know
exactly what happened you pointed out in
in your testimony a different effects
tarp head on the large banks and the
small banks as it is played out the
large banks have benefited the most and
gotten larger at the expense of the
small banks have any of you found that
Treasury or anyone else is worried about
that impact or that it was even
considered when tarp funds are being
handed out senator there is no doubt
that there has been increased
concentration in the banking industry
since tart dollars were were put into
the system and we are very concerned
that the numbers indicate that there
will be even more concentration as
smaller banks under great economic
stress either fail or are gobbled up by
larger banks we can find no evidence
that at the time the initial tarp
program was designed and money was put
in to these banks that the Treasury was
concerned about the increasing
concentration no sir okay go ahead thank
you um sir buddy sir Carver yeah thanks
thanks foreigners thank you all for for
joining us today i have a question them
is one I want to go back to something
that I almost every might just suspend
briefly a fesse Warren do you have to
leave I'm told we had to lead a quarter
of to go to the White House and let me
want to let two senators few a couple
three minutes let send a car for ask
couple three questions yes sir are you
able to do that of course yeah thanks
just first before I asked about a small
Bank situation with respect to the home
affordable mortgage modification program
I think you use the word bribe
in conjunction with servicers what I
said through during sunrise in the
banking committee we're trying to figure
out why weren't these different mortgage
modification programs working and part
of the testimony that we heard was that
if of all the key stakeholders that we
need cooperation from one is we need a
cooperation of the services they were
being asked to do work in continuing
conjunction of modifying these mortgages
they were in danger of being sued for if
for the work that they were doing by
investors and they weren't getting
compensation for it so here's the ring
as to do work there in some jeopardy of
they thought of being sued for their
involvement and what we heard from that
one incentivize them to be part of the
solution compensate them for the work
they're asked to be doing so I don't
know that I'd use the term term bribed
that that's where we ended up why I
never again it was Treasury and a number
of other folks who thought that that
they deserve some kind of compensation
in order to to participate let me ask
you a question about the small banks if
I can and thank you for bearing with us
here I think you've expressed here just
before maybe I arrived concern about the
small banks ability to rape repay their
tarp obligations and in fact as you know
the number of small banks have have
missed the required dividend payments
let me just says what is your
recommended solution to that problem
well I I always want to be a modest we
we can go as far as I day to take us and
try to try to point out where the
problems are I will say in the case of
small banks we have been urging Treasury
for I think more than half a year now to
get ahead of the coming problems with
commercial real estate they are
disproportionately those those loans are
disproportionately concentrated in
intermediate size and smaller banks and
they are not evenly spread among those
banks they they concentrate within that
in certain banks and that that's going
to create additional profound stresses
on the financial system so i'm i'm
afraid i'm going to i'm going to have to
back up to the role that we are we are
not policymakers
but where we've urged Treasury to move
is is in that direction to try to start
wrestling now before the crisis is upon
us with commercial real estate loans in
particular summarize your answer in like
one or two sentences in terms of what to
what is your recommend recommendations
for solving this problem just summarize
just very briefly fair enough I'm sorry
sir it's it's that we acknowledge and
deal with the obvious coming problem in
commercial real estate that Treasury
work with the small financial
institutions to develop a plan for how
they're going to pay their way out of
tarp and that Treasury establish a
program to deal with the number of small
banks who are not able to make their
tarp prepayments all right thanks very
much thank you sir Thank You senator
Thank You professor Warren very very
much so deeply appreciate your service
arrest and your other obligations and
committee will continue hearing from is
mr. brosky and then element thank you my
apologize for for leaving and thank you
all forever thank you okay Rob ski if
you could elaborate a little bit more on
their report about GM Chrysler dealer
dealership dismissals if you were by the
administration and resultant job loss
and other consequences you felt the
active to speed Lee and I do not want to
put words in your mouth but you felt
that there was not as appropriate it
should have been could you expand on
that place sure and I also note that I
think that as a result of you know the
White House based on the White House's
reaction to our report there's little
chance that I will be called away by an
invitation to the White House anytime
consider to have to mrs. hearing
essentially what we tried to do in this
in this in this audit report is with
respect to I like about JJ colander sale
every question with respect to respect
to the Treasury piece of this report
what we tried to do is we looked at the
process what was the process that the
auto team used
income making its ultimate decision to
reject the pitch by GM that they were
going to terminate their dealerships
over the course of five years and its
response and its viability determination
that it needed to accelerate that
process which ultimately resulted with
Treasury's encouragement of using the
bankruptcy process to basically get
around the state franchise laws to
terminate them all at once and what GM
did was they actually terminated the
ability of those dealers to get new cars
for about 18 months and allow them to
wind down well Christ are also taking
the cue just within three weeks knocked
them out with immediate terminations and
what we found was that when engaging in
this process there were several flaws in
that process the decision-making process
first of all they the diligence that you
would expect and making a decision of
this consequence particularly given the
timing you know we were obviously in the
midst of the greatest recession in
generations they didn't do any of the
modeling that you would expect the
analytical review that you would expect
essentially they talked to a number of
industry experts mostly Wall Street
analysts and ask them their opinion and
the opinion that came back was generally
yes it's important to reduce the dealer
networks that there's there's there's
some degree of competition to of too
much competition particularly in metro
areas and city areas but basically that
opinion was not Universal there was at
least one expert that treasury spoke to
and others that we spoke to that that
dissented from that opinion but there
really wasn't until after decision was
made any other diligence or worked on
second there was no consideration of
protected cost savings to to the
dealerships it wasn't a factor at all
and again that wasn't done until
afterwards in response to an inquiry
from Congress and then third which I
think we found was the biggest flaw in
this decision making process there was
apparently no consideration given
whatsoever to the fact that they were
those decisions were going to involve
potentially shuttering thousands of
small businesses putting tens of
thousands of jobs in jeopardy given the
timing the very same time when we had
such a jobless epidemic I think in you
know we were looking in earlier last
year 700,000 jobs lost per month
and that I think is one of one of one of
the big flaws of this process now it may
wear you how I have been that had they
analyzed all of that data and looked at
what you know and did the benefit of the
benefits to GM and Chrysler versus the
job losses and the broader economic
impact perhaps they may have come to the
same decision but from what we saw we
didn't see the evidence to support the
idea that these dealer that GM and
Chrysler would have foundered or gone
out of business had they not accelerate
determination we saw no evidence to
support that and we certainly didn't see
any evidence of the necessary balancing
that the government must do we believe
before making a decision like this next
question it's the good news is the the
tarp losses are less or less they're
still that implies that there's going to
be some result in losses and the
question is where as words that going to
come from is that is it the auto dealers
is it AIG and if where are the loss is
going to be coming from and what can be
done to minimize them Treasury's most
recent estimate put the losses at a
total of one hundred and five billion
again this is their estimate forty five
billion dollars from AIG 25 billion
dollars from the auto industry including
their their auto financing arms and the
homework the mortification program
that's a 50 billion dollars now nothing
can be done about that because that
program is is a subsidy there's no
intention there's no way to recoup any
any money from there for the auto
companies in AIG the horses probably
left the barn you know our ability to
the decisions that were made the terms
that were provided the amount of money
that was provided is essentially money
that's alpha door the best that we can
do is is that hope that given the the
restructuring of these companies that
they returned to profitability that
their their market capitalization
increases there certainly are plans with
respect to GM for an IPO it's been
announced hopefully in the fourth
quarter that will hopefully get the ball
rolling AIG can successfully liquidate
its assets there's plans now for an IPO
for one of its subsidiaries and
hopefully if the economy continues to
improve
market conditions continue to improve
hopefully these numbers will come down
even further but the bottom line is is
that if people get more jobs if housing
markets rebound and the economy improves
we're going to really improve our
ability to get this money back all right
but so though I'm at times expiring with
dark conditions that require the might
be repaid under what conditions where
the economy's doing better there have
greater sales or what what's under what
conditions really we really we're done
just about done to equity investments in
these in the auto companies and in the
and in AIG there is there is some
outstanding debt that's associated with
as well but the the lion's share is
equity so basically we're going to have
to liquidate our ownership interest at
some point and that can only is going to
happen if these companies go public or
AIG is public but if it's if it has and
is able to shed enough assets be able to
pay off its federal reserve obligations
first because again Treasury doesn't get
a nickel until all the federal reserve
arias Federal Reserve's work for AIG is
taken care of and only at that point and
for the auto companies it really is a
question of how successful and
profitable they are and how they can how
the Treasury can liquidate its
investment it's a grass that you got
five minutes plus two minutes to a half
minutes you get a lot of times okay
thank you very much i probably won't
take it because I gotta go over to
agriculture to ask a questions over
there first of all I'm glad this senator
Baucus asks a question that he did about
car dealerships I would have asked
similar question but let me follow up on
a specific inference that you did about
General Motors not consistently
following its stated criteria and that
there was little documentation of the
decision-making process to terminate or
retain dealerships I heard from
dealerships that strongly believe that
there was a little rhyme or reason to
their termination notices some believe
the rationale was always evolving
meaning that the criteria was very
subjective could you elaborate on this
point and tell us what you learned by
looking at General Motors data it the
General Motors originally said and
additionally said to Congress was that
it was going to
soon objective criteria they actually
made comments to Congress that they
didn't want to have the dangers of a
subjective process of case-by-case basis
that they wanted it to be an objective
process so they put out some metrics and
they describe those metrics to us
different scoring internal scoring
methods that they use and and other
types of objective data the problem is
when we reach behind that data they
didn't always follow it in fact in some
cases there was some pretty significant
variances from what the objective data
indicated versus what the the actual
decision making process so in phase one
the first phase of the of their
terminations it was about they said
certain criteria if a score was below 70
then that meant that dealership was
going to be terminated about forty
percent of the dealerships that were
below that number were actually retained
so that suggests that it was done on a
more case-by-case basis so we went back
and we asked GM you know for
explanations and the explanations we got
were general they acknowledged first of
all that it was in fact that this was
the objective criteria was more of a
guidelines and that there was some
degree of case-by-case looking at it so
one of the things they came back to us
with was well we decided to when we look
at this number we decided to keep some
of the dealers and our rural networks
because they are that's where you know
some of our dissenting experts on the
whole auto teams theory you know pointed
to the fact that the American auto
dealerships and manufacturing companies
have a competitive advantage in rural
areas so again they told us that but
then when we looked at the ultimate
numbers of what the determinations are
nearly half of them are in rural areas
which was in contrast what GM's original
pitch so we asked for documentation we
asked for okay let's see the back up and
there wasn't any basically the
explanations that we received were after
the fact reconstructed at times it took
them weeks to get back to us to try to
reconstruct and give us an explanation
why a particular dealership was
terminated so basically we have a
process that lacked transparency it
lacked accountability and one of the
reasons one of the things that we fought
for the auto we fought the auto team for
is having put in the wheels in motion
for these terminations on these
accelerated terminations within the
chaos of a bankruptcy but
had some obligation to then oversee that
process and we think that they'd
abdicated that responsibility and it
resulted in what we saw with GM and in
Chrysler which was a much more
subjective process upfront and they were
upfront but saying hey we used a very
subjective process but they didn't even
have the basic process of an appeal
process and we fought the auto team for
not following up and providing that
oversight once they set the wheels in
motion last week the security Exchange
Commission announced that has settled
with Goldman for 550 million the SCC
allege that Goldman misled investors by
telling them that the pool of mortgages
were put together by an independent
advisor when in fact both the hedge fund
manager who created the security and
Goldman itself were secretly betting
that the investment would go bad while
these particular transactions did not
involve AIG there were reports that
similar deals did at our last hearing I
asked you if you were examining whether
AIG may have been similarly misled by
goldman since AIG is a tarp recipient
losses on these securities may have
contributed the need for taxpayer
bailout of AIG could you explain or
could you give an update on your
independent assessment of whether any
arg taxpayer-subsidized payments to
goldman were based on this kind of fraud
and if so whether any of the fraud can
be recovered from gold we've opened a
broader investigation looking into
exactly these issues we've actually
assembled an internal mini Task Force
which combines elements from our
investigations as well as our audit
division i put my chief of staff in
charge of it because i think it's an
important priority for our organization
and we're looking at precisely these
issues whether or not the taxpayer has a
remedy a civil you know potential civil
remedy either on behalf of eight through
I AIG or through the Federal Reserve
through its maiden lane facilities
because these you know to the extent
that we're not through it I'm sorry not
through its main lame facilities but but
through its its credit line because the
end as well as the tarp money back
stopped to see whether there's any
potential civil remedies here and we're
also looking at maiden lane 2 we've
started taking a look at that and seeing
if there's any potential civil remedies
on behalf of the Federal Reserve or
behalf of the taxpayer if there is in
fact fraud underlying these our
investigation is that it's pretty pretty
initial stages it's a lot of information
and a lot of documents but we're working
on it okay Thank You mr. chairman and
where you getting back my time thank you
everybody Thank You mr. chairman mr.
burn off che have a few questions about
the auto bailouts and the report you
issued on Monday first you are able to
do were you able to tell if dealership
closures will do anything to increase
the profitability of GM or Chrysler all
I can tell you senator is that's that's
the basis of the theory that the auto
team was working under it is a theory
that is shared by a number of financial
analysts on Wall Street generally
speaking even those those experts that
we spoke to that dissented from the auto
team's overall strategy did believe that
it was important for overall for some of
the dealerships in in metro areas where
there might be over saturation and the
reason being is basically if there's if
two dealers are close to each other and
competing with one another that drives
prices down so the idea is that prices
will go up the consumer will pay more
for a car and that where GM and Chrysler
will save money is that they'll have to
have fewer incentive payments to the
dealerships that's the theory we have
not done any work to test that theory
you know going forward and to see what
happens second when looking at the
dealership closing plans in general are
at any individual closures did you find
anything to suggest that either the car
companies our treasury gave any
consideration to the fact that many of
the dealerships that were closed were
profitable for themselves and for GM and
Chrysler Treasury I was it was not a
consideration at all for the companies
themselves they acknowledged that they
closed profitable dealership I'm
I'm gonna give you two examples that
they're right in my backyard and I'm in
a Cincinnati Metro being on the short
side of the since nine metro area being
over in Northern Kentucky I went to high
school with a young man by the name of
Zimmer they had Zimmer Chrysler Plymouth
but they didn't have jeep Zimmer
Chrysler Plymouth and they headed for 90
years Rob key chevrolet they had just
invested eight million dollars in a new
plant I mean a new showcase and they had
been profitable for the 60 years of
their existence Zimmer had been
profitable for all 90 years of their
existence both of those places were
closed because they they had to compete
with all of the other major Chrysler
dealerships and General Motors
dealerships in the metro area of
Cincinnati and they were on the wrong
side of the river now that to me is kind
of most the most unfair thing I've ever
witnessed in American business when you
are running a profit and no it wasn't a
small profit they just weren't selling
enough cars 450 cars and one and six
hundred and another then when you
consider the big picture of the
metropolitan area they were at the lower
end as you were saying they're seventy
percent and I can't understand that how
is that going to help Chrysler and
General Motors make a profit centered it
is it is entirely counterintuitive and
indeed in our report we cite we took a
sample market but for a Chrysler
dealership and the dealership that got a
nated was the dealership that sold the
most cars in that market they sold the
most she was a jeep dealer they sold the
most cars more cars than any other
chrysler you know jeep dodge dealership
in that entire market there are scores
by every objective criteria were the
highest it was the best performing
dealer and chrysler was up front they
said the reason why they got rid of him
was that he had in his franchise
agreement the ability to prevent other
chrysler dealer ships from selling jeeps
within a certain radius he didn't play
ball so they got rid of him this is a
story that we've heard and we've heard
it over and over again and and you know
to a certain extent you on the on the GM
side lack of a documentation of the
process on the Chrysler side the lack of
an ability to appeal that's been
remedied somewhat by Congress is action
by giving them a right to arbitrate let
me ask the last question I want to get
the stro inning this is a follow up on
the edgy a lawsuit waiver that earlier
that I asked professor Warren but do
either of you have you looked at this
latest giveaway in the form of a oh geez
legal rights to sue our work on AIG has
really looked at the indicators of
financial performance for itself its
companies and its ability to restructure
itself sell off its businesses and the
like we do have an ongoing engagement
though senator that will be looking into
issues associated with decisions that
were made with the credit default swaps
risks that the AIG financial products
division which was a major cause for the
downfall of AIG were and also were they
returned one hundred percent on the yes
we are looking at the whole affair the
extent to which the which parties were
in the room when decisions were made
what was the basis for the decisions
what criteria was followed and evaluate
thank you both for your questions Sarah
Carper thanks mr. chairman general again
welcome and thank you for joining us
today and for your testimony and for for
your responses some of the questions I'd
want to ask
with the auto dealers have been
responded to an hour going to set those
aside for for now I just want to go back
up to 30,000 two feet and look again at
the avatar program and ask you a free
system some comments on it with respect
to the if you will the capital infusion
that we made from the tarp program into
the larger financial institutions their
ability to meet their dividends
requirements on our preferred stock
their ability to buy back their
preferred stock their ability to make
payments as we exercised our warrants
how is that going I think overall
especially with the larger financial
institutions it's going very well you
know there's been more money paid back
now then has that is currently
outstanding you know a lot of the larger
players the through the warrant
repurchase and auction process Treasury
has seen nice returns our recent report
that we did on that process although we
saw some some some issues about the
process that gave us some very serious
concerns as far as the results they're
getting the prices close to the internal
estimates that which we all believe are
reasonable and we worked with Professor
Warren in looking at that issue so I
think there is some good news the
problem is going forward is the
strongest have paid back the most
profitable have paid back now we're now
we're dealing with in the capital
purchase program with those institutions
that have not yet been able to pay back
and we in our report we list about a
hundred and five institutions that have
missed dividend payments we've seen a
handful of failures usually 105 of mr.
dividend payment have missed a dividend
out of a universe of how large and are
these generally smaller institutions are
generally smaller we have the the total
number of the dollar value it's about
it's not an insignificant amount 150
million dollars but but compared to the
amount of repay that have been repaid by
the larger institutions it's somewhat
less and we're also seeing restructuring
and recapitalizations which we go
through in this report and that's when a
bank is struggling bank this receive
tarp funds as we struggling and and
frequently on the verge of failure and
Treasuries on the verge of basically
getting wiped out with complete loss to
the taxpayer they've been agreeing to
reach truck
sure often at by taking a haircut on the
value of the taxpayer investment to help
the bank draw and attract more private
capital to changing the ratios bound
usually dropping from preferred status
dropping down the ladder to a common or
or mandatory convertible convertible
stock and that's another area where
we're seeing some losses but Treasury is
trying to try to get some value out of
it and I think that's a process that
that is um you know is a complicated
process and one we're going to be
looking at more closely through our
audit process soon all right with with
respect to the auto the auto companies a
GM and Chrysler my recollection was that
GM made some repayments I want to say
six or seven billion dollars I was some
search and I heard they were taking
money out of one pocket and answer like
paying Peter with Paul's money is again
can you just refresh my memory on that
but also talk talk with us about the IPO
process which i think is going to begin
at least with GM later this year and
hopefully with Chrysler next year
essentially with respect to the debt
repayment your Treasury provided GM with
about forty nine and a half billion
dollars it was done in a number of
different payments through its
bankruptcy process but a chunk of that
was put in an escrow account at that was
GM's escrow account was part of that
that support and for a while GM couldn't
access money from that esco account
without Treasury's position Trevor
Treasury's permission they'd have to
send a memo and say your Treasury we
want to access this money and we want to
use it for X or for why ultimately every
pen part of the 49 half billion dollars
was probably received equity in return
part of it was preferred shares and part
of it was a approximately seven billion
dollar loan that loan was repaid by
money they came out of that tarp escrow
account so the money had gone over to GM
so his in GM's possession as part of the
bailout but it was a segregated account
of TARP funds so GM sent a series of
memos over to Treasury which said your
treasure we'd like to use take money out
of the the escrow account of TARP funds
and use it to pay back the tarp loan a
Treasury said okay all right talk to us
about the the
public offerings jameis suggests that
they hope to have at least one later
this year to begin I think buying out
the federal government the taxpayers for
our 6061 percent equity position I met
was the CEO of a Chrysler a month or two
ago and he indicated they hope to have
returned to profitability by the end of
this year and to be able to to conduct
the first of a series of IPOs I think we
have maybe a ten or twenty percent
equity position in Chrysler can you just
give us an update on those two please
sure our information is is large it from
from information announcements by
Treasury and the companies but
Treasury's as hired they've contracted
with lazard freres to advise them in the
IPO it is contemplated that it is
there's potential would be an IPO in the
fourth quarter of this year of General
Motors there's a there's a lot of
variables for that of course I don't
think that in that IPO Treasury would
look good at its entire investment I
think what's being discussed is that it
would bring it down so treasure right
now has a sixty one percent equity
ownership in GM that they would sell a
portion that would bring them down below
majority ownership but I think a lot of
it is is very dependent on a lot of
different factors but I think that they
are looking towards the GM and Treasury
are looking towards an IPO in the fourth
quarter of this year Chrysler i think
senator your information is more up to
date than mine alright mister mister
Jimmy I just note that in terms of with
respect to this IPL with particularly
with GM I'm pleased to hear that it's
we're not going to try to recoup the
entire 61 percent all at once put the
idea of it'll be had a patient investor
and hopefully over time is the market
returns in GM which has a frankly a
bunch of good products in a pipeline
including I think they launched the
vault this this fall that maybe we can
recover all that money thanks I have one
more question
then I didn't have to leave in instead
Carper if you want to take over it be
five mr. ask you I want explore where we
are on the total federal effort to
support the economy you've done a new
calculation of the toll federal effort
to support the economy found that the
toll has actually gone up from I think
about three trillion dollars to 3.7
trillion since last year that's a new
number I guess that's a toll expended or
guaranteed respect to federal the Fed
Treasury sharp agencies like FDIC and
FHA if you could just expand on that and
delineate frankly you know what the
components are why it's grown in the
last year sure the areas that we saw are
mostly related to the housing markets
really Fannie and Freddie the direct
support of them or support of their
products so a break down the the biggest
number is the Federal Reserve's purchase
of Freddie and Fannie mortgage-backed
securities that's about that added that
went up about 650 billion dollars in the
past year the Federal Reserve is also
purchased directly debt of Fannie and
Freddie that went up about 70 billion
and it's program of buying Treasuries
United States government debt that
increased about 125 billion dollars for
HUD increases in fh a guarantee loan
guarantees and Ginnie Mae guarantees on
mortgage-backed securities that
increased about five hundred billion
dollars that was that again that sort of
direct support to the housing market as
well as the institutions obviously who
are receiving those guarantees and on
the Treasury side we saw increases in
again its backstop of Fannie and Freddie
about 85 billion dollars more in
purchase of preferred shares and in
those two entities about 50 billion
dollars more in response to the euro
debt crisis by through commitments to
the IMF particularly respect to the
bailout of Greece and about 65 billion
dollar increase in support for student
loans the purchases of student loans and
and asset-backed securities involving
student loans obviously those numbers
add up to a lot more than 700 billion
and that's because those are offset by
the reductions in tarp and
a lot of the Federal Reserve's liquidity
programs which have which had been
closed down entirely well that's a big
number so how much that's real well it
senses net I mean it's all real the 700
billion dollar increase is all about the
37 trillion oh well it's all real I mean
it's all actual expenditures and
guarantees it's not as we make clear in
here that doesn't mean that the United
States government is at risk of loss of
things went 78 west as Federal Reserve
programs are almost entirely securitized
I'm sorry collateral collateralized most
of these programs are collateralized so
when and sometimes there's even some
some double counting so my example is is
that you know if if the Fed buys an
agency mortgage-backed security that's
guaranteed by Fannie and Freddie well
it's guaranteed by Fannie and Freddie so
the Federal Reserve isn't necessarily at
risk of loss there now of course if
there was a loss of Fannie and Freddie
then Treasury would come in and increase
it you know purchase more preferred
stock to backstop that loss if those
securities go bad and then of course
standing behind that is the house which
is collateral so that's the that's the
protection the Treasury and FHFA who
oversee Fannie and Freddie if there's a
default under one of those mortgages
that backs the mortgage-backed security
again there's recourse to collateral you
know similarly you know for the the
asset-backed security program with
student loans there are loans that
underlie those and you know there would
be a chance to be recourse to that and
of course fan Ian and I'm sorry FHA and
the gini Mac programs again those are
all secured by the actual houses and
there's some overlap and those numbers
because generally Ginnie Mae buys pools
and securitizers loans FHA loans still
the number is up for three the 37 which
indicates that you know the greater
financial federal support for the
economy because we're not on the woods
no no absolutely and even when it's it's
collateralized and even when there's
some double counting each of these
agencies has felt compelled to increase
their amounts and their commitments to
these programs by is a staggering amount
of money i have to leave what's what's
kind of the one thing that you want to
leave with this committee at this point
i mean i think you have a great job
but I want to let you say it you want to
say tell us what you think we should
know this committee at this point you
know I think that one of the enduring
frustrations that we have although
Treasury has come a long way in a lot of
different areas for transparency and
accountability it still has some ways to
go and I think that transparency isn't
just for transparency sake and as I said
in my opening comments regarding the
housing program it makes the program's
better it makes them more credible and I
think we're treasury falls down on
transparency whether it's in the housing
program or its worn disposition process
by by not documenting conversations or
having the you know formal processes and
those negotiations or in many other
areas it hurts the credibility of the
program in ways that are entirely
unnecessary thank you very much certain
else oh you're next in you're in charge
okay senator have you been cold on it
spice revolver we had two rounds and
we've had two rounds before you showed
up I'll call on you in just a minute
good morning wood would you tell me of
the 36 or 34 billion that we expect to
lose on the autumn Oh automobile bailout
do we expect to get any of that back
when GM goes out with an initial
offering I think the projection for that
loss assumes the paying back through the
through the initial public offering so I
think that the reason why the number
isn't much higher than that is that this
is the estimate these are the estimates
that either CBO or OMB or Treasury they
all have different estimates out there
but this is their estimate assuming that
there is an IPO assuming that there is
that payments are made as a result of
what will be left over how do you break
that 34 billion down between Chrysler
and GM I don't have those numbers we go
off the aggregate numbers that were
provided so I said I can I could go back
and ask Treasury for that breakdown and
provided to
okay and with regard to the 36 billion
that we're going to lose with regard to
AIG can you give any kind of breakdown
on that sure I mean that the basic idea
that projection is based on AIG
liquidates it's you know some of its
larger holdings and gets cash money back
for those holdings and AIA and aliko
have been the ones that have been
prominent Inoue's we indicate some
others in the quarterly report first
thing that happens is the Federal
Reserve gets paid back and Federal
Reserve has a number of different
facilities so for example when those
those foreign subsidies are sold the
Federal Reserve owns preferred shares
and special purpose vehicles so that
gets paid off first once that gets paid
off then it's extended line of credit
that it has that has to get paid off
then after all that occurs in the
Federal Reserve is made whole then
Treasury gets in line and our interest
right now is in preferred shares which
would presumably get redeemed at that
point but basically it's going to only
happen through increased profitability
and really increased asset sales so
since the Treasury money really went in
in two tranches both both equity
tranches the first 140 billion dollars
really went directly to pay down the lot
did the Federal Reserve's credit line it
almost I don't even know if it actually
even passed through AIG so it's hard to
tie that to any particular business and
then the additional 30 billion hasn't
been fully drawn they actually haven't
taken a draw down on that since since
mid-march that you could tie to
individual activities because a G is
required to identify how they're
planning to use the money each time they
come to the tail on that the 36 billion
loss is a figure that you are projecting
in the future but conceivably it could
be less if arg is getting more
profitable to be clear that the 36
billion dollars is cbos most recent
estimate Treasury actually estimates a
higher loss of 45 billion in its most
recent estimate but the projection is is
that after all is said and done after
the Federal Reserve is paid off after
Treasuries owners
which is in preferred as well as is
potentially in common eighty percent of
the stock after all that liquidation is
leftover that we're still going to be
again depending on who you speak to but
Treasury still 45 billion dollars in the
hole and to put that in context I think
there's about forty seven billion
outstanding so basically they're looking
at verses what's currently outstanding
is a potentially a near complete loss
originally tarp was looked upon as a
program to keep the country from going
into financial meltdown later on it was
a program thought to be an assistance to
resuscitate back to life the housing
market and that hasn't worked too well
would you give us your comments on that
I think that your your your perception
is widely held and I think that the the
housing program has been a great
disappointment with the numbers that
just came out official yesterday and
they're contained in our report during
the the sixteen seventeen months since
the program's but announced there's been
fewer than four hundred thousand
permanent modifications of those only
165,000 are actually resulting from the
tar portion of the program the rest are
being done by by fannie and freddie
which has you know slightly different
standards more forgiving standards and
so the numbers have been very
disappointing one of the problems that i
highlighted earlier senator is that
there's no treasury still refuses this
is one of the most basic frustrations we
have to give benchmarks what is its
goals what is it what is it actually
trying to accomplish with this 50
billion dollars that they've asked for
how many people do they really hope to
say keep to stay in their homes and all
they're offering our are frankly quite
meaningless metric of offers to help
three to four million people so i think
that unfortunately until treasury comes
clean and really acknowledges what its
goals and expectations are it's
inevitable that there's going to be
perceptions of the programs just an
outright failure mr. Hillman we've
looked at the home affordable
modification program as well as part of
our oversight of the tarp
program and one of the major points that
we have made is that the program that is
up and standing and running today is a
first lien modification program and
there are many other programs that
treasury has announced but have yet to
be fully designed and implemented the
first lien program for example was
announced a year before it was
ultimately implemented that level of
urgency is contrast very sharply to the
activities of the tarp program as it
related to supporting the banking
environment weeks after legislation was
passed capital injections were made into
those institutions to maintain their
stability and financial and financial
stability with the foreclosure issues it
seems that the urgency has not been as
similar to what has taken place on the
banking side one of the issues that
we've raised has to do with the level of
resources that Treasury has devoted to
this area and have recommended that
Treasury reevaluate the resources that
it needs to both design and successfully
implement that program to date those
efforts have resulted in a Treasury
reducing its workload in certain areas
within the home affordable modification
program and we think that needs to be
revisited and your estimate is or
someone's estimate is there's going to
be a twenty billion dollar loss on that
home the HAMP program Home Affordable
Modification Program its at right twenty
to twenty billion loss the amount of
expenditures by the HAMP program up to a
commitment of fifty billion dollars is a
total expenditure to the program with no
expectation that there would be any
dollars that were being returned so
whatever is ultimately spent will be
considered a loss to the program well I
must say that this senator voted against
the first round of tarp I was persuaded
to vote for the reduced tranche of tarp
in anticipation that it was going to
help the housing crisis which in my
state of Florida over three hundred and
ten thousand properties have gone into
foreclosure and in June alone of this
year 51,000 new foreclosures were filed
so needless to say I'm not very happy
with this part of TARP senator bunning
Thank You chairman I've got to want to
follow up on the Chairman's questioning
of mr. Bernanke mr. Brodowski there is a
similar pattern in your testimony when
you talk about treasures Treasuries
handling of different tarp programs in
the HAMP program for modified mortgages
Treasury refuses as you say the scent
set benchmarks for success when it sold
warrants for companies that receive tarp
funds Treasury did not document
important parts of the negotiations well
enough fully one year after your office
recommended evaluation system and
internal controls for the public-private
investment program treasury has refused
to do so despite claims that it would
and the list goes on and on mr. Byrne
our ski why do you feel and why do you
think Treasury is so afraid of real
transparency and accountability in the
handling of tarp money senator there's
some questions I can answer in some that
are that are frankly beyond me and I
don't really understand just want you to
answer the ones you can I don't really
understand why it is that they won't
provide basic benchmarks I don't
understand why you demand that what's
that I all I can do is make
recommendations I have
no ability to compel them to do so I
have no idea why they would not commit
to fully document every conversation
that they have when they're negotiating
on behalf of the American taxpayer in
the Warren program where they're
providing information in consistently to
different banks some banks get the
benefit of knowing what the price
Treasury is likely to accept other banks
are not I can't imagine I truly can't
imagine why they wouldn't immediately
come come forth and say you know what
sigtarp you guys are right we made a
mistake but i will tell you those are
words that we do not hear we don't hear
it in we didn't hear it with respect to
the automobile warrant we didn't hear it
when we talked about the negotiations
that led to payment of a hundred cents
on the dollar for AIG we never hear any
acknowledgement that they are fallible
that they are human there's a lot of
pressure but charge I mean I just remind
you that the only thing they needed to
do to renew tarp to 700 billion for one
is for the treasurer secretary of the
Treasury to write letter to himself
there should be more accountability for
a 700 billion dollar slush fund that is
not being used as Senator Nelson said
for the purpose for which it was created
do you think in one instant that this
panel and other senators would have
voted for tarp had they known it was
going to the major bankers in New York
City if they would have if secretary
Paulson woulda came to this Congress and
said by the way we're not going to do
after bad assets are toxic assets in the
system we're going to give this money to
the bankers and let them work it out do
you think one minute that they would
have gotten permission for seven hundred
billion dollars I certainly understand
what your view is on this the
frustration level with the members of
Congress and the use of the tarp funds
is just so outraged
about what they did and how they did it
and the misuse of language when they
sold the program to the Congress of the
United States and we want you to do
everything in your power to make them
accountable that's why we voted you into
that position and so far we're pretty
pleased with what you're doing but you
can go farther you can make them
accountable for every penny they spend
and we will continue to strive to do so
senator well thank you very much senator
Carper let me just say to mr. barofsky
I've known center gone in for a long
time and that's some of the highest
praise I've ever heard him give to a
witness I do appreciate his words were
pretty pleased he's take this is a good
day every day I have my job I considered
to be a good day senator I feel that way
too about mine I am I've been talking
with Amy over to my staff person right
behind me and trying to just look at
this again from 30,000 feet to talk book
my recollections when last
administration came to us and asked who
asked us to fund the Troubled Asset
program they explained that this was to
buy toxic assets through a liquid
untradeable and that was a good way to
help strengthen the balance sheets of
the financial institutions that were at
risk my recollection was that they
decided to take this different approach
after he provided the approval for the
money because I think some other
countries may be in Europe maybe England
had decided to take take this approach
and thought that it was a smarter
approaches is my recollection faulty or
is that is that true either either of
you please that is consistent we did a
report on the capital purchase program I
think of november of last year where we
talked about the the initial decision
making process that led to the capital
purchase program and the equity
investments and one of the things that
we found was that that was a factor what
what the Europeans were doing I think
another significant factor was the
conclusion that setting up the
mechanisms for
purchase of toxic assets was going to
take a lot longer than they felt that
this situation there was a sense of
immediacy that I think Chairman Bernanke
thought it would take you know three or
four months to set up that process and
that the there just wasn't enough time
because of the continuing spiraling down
the financial crisis that that's my
understanding a part of their exponent
of a mr. Hillman and you all of us are
better quarterbacks on Monday morning
then we huge there on Saturday or Sunday
when were playing the game but looking
at the decision that was made to not use
these funds to to purchase these
illiquid assets did we make the right
decision in our view there's a lot of
trade-offs associated with or not you're
taking away toxic assets on the balance
sheets or putting capital injections
into the institutions however in looking
at those two options the option of
taking those toxic assets off the
balance sheets was an enormous exercise
fraught with a lot of problems in
valuing those illiquid assets having
having those assets be maintained within
Treasury for a long period of time to
sustain their profitability and then
returning them back to the marketplace
it would have been an enormous
undertaking fraught with many risks
providing for capital injections into
the institutions hopefully increasing
their stability hopefully increasing
their ability to lend to businesses and
consumers has in hindsight turned out to
be a program which has resulted in some
profitability thus far for the Treasury
in the federal government at least as it
relates to the larger institutions who
have paid back those purchases of
securities whether it turns out to be a
positive result for the small banking
institutions is something that is yet to
be determined right now the there are
four bank failures within small
institutions who received tarp funds
there's 74 institutions that are on the
high-risk list of the saving for can you
just quantify for it's just roughly how
much tarp money is involved with
China billions of dollars tens of
billions hundreds of millions just just
very roughly fortunately it's tens of
billions of dollars the majority of the
funding had gone to the larger
institutions it was based upon the asset
sizes as to what types of capital
injections that were made Treasury has
received back seventy-two percent of its
204 billion in tarp investments to date
and if you add the amounts received from
interest and dividends and warrants
they've received eighty percent of what
they paid out to date but that remaining
twenty percent that the smaller banks
are holding is going to be a much more
complicated task in returning those
funds because of the concerns associated
with the profitability of those
institutions you roughly quantify that
twenty percent in terms of how much
money we're talking about is it 20
billion dollars is it 30 you don't just
give us a ballpark it's in the 30 to 40
billion right okay as my I think what
mr. Brodsky is saying earlier with
respect to I want to say it was AIG the
the amount that were on the hook with
AIG Arizona maybe between 35 and 45 and
we're hearing we probably won't see that
money recover least Treasury doesn't
believe so and we're looking at a
similar exposure really fairly similar
with respect to the small banks and the
question of whether or not we'll be able
to get recovered that money is still I
think it up in the air is that right
absolutely okay I'm going to go back to
GM and Chrysler I'm like like some of my
colleague who actually follow the
Ottawas we used to have dela was less
state to add any auto assembly
operations and the east coast between
main and Florida we lost both of our
Chrysler plant or GM plant within the
last 18 months and we even call have fog
close to work closely with the auto
industry for four years and I'm
encouraged that with GM with its lineup
and I mentioned the vault I call it the
most advertised car that's never been
sold but it's about to let to be sold
here in a couple of months and we'll see
how it how it does but well we've been
working for with an auto industry got an
auto industry that historically sold
between 15 16 17 million units a year
last year I think they sold
10 I think they sure there may be on
track to do about 11 quality of our cars
is improved and i think that the
perception that that quality is improved
is finally sunk in on the consumer so i
tend to be more optimistic than than not
with respect particular with GM and
Chrysler I'm told is about to to lecture
I would haven't had a whole lot in the
pipeline for the last couple of years
but a lot of new products that we should
see in in the year to come so we'll keep
our fingers crossed cause their last
question I want to ask you hey want to
go back to
finished
tutions to to modify principal and let's
just say everybody in this room we all
live in the same will say the same
neighborhood and the those of us at this
table and those of us who privilege to
sit on this side of the ice we have our
mortgages are underwater and we would
like for our lender to forgive part of
our principal maybe we're working hard
maybe we're not working hard in order to
come up with the money to meet our
mortgage payments I will say everybody
else in the audience here is doing the
dead level best even though their
mortgages are might be underwater to
meet their obligations and there's a
concern I've heard a voice from others
that if some kind of preference is given
in terms of principal forgiveness for
those who either are unable or maybe
unwilling to do what it takes to meet
their obligation its it really it acts
as an incentive to those who are working
hard to play by the rules to say well
why shouldn't I just walk away from from
my obligations to could y'all come in on
that sure um the classic moral hazard
issue with any mortgage modification
program and and to be clear it's it's
not just principal reduction it's really
hampus it exists with with interest rate
reductions it's all sort of based on the
idea that if someone's in default or an
imminent default they're going to get a
benefit with someone who's who's
continuing to make the payments you know
doesn't have that and then that also
creates a moral hazard I think in
certain way we have to appreciate the
fact that as a whole tarp is jumped into
the deep end of the moral hazard pool
when we're looking at the bailout for
the financial institutions or the
homeowners there's going to be a degree
of moral hazards that said play with all
of these programs with specifically
though with principal reduction first of
all you know as based on our
recommendation and our discussion back
and forth with Treasury that's reflected
in our report principal reduction would
under you know basically as we're
discussing it would only occur if it was
in the best interest of the investor if
they run the net present value test and
it indicates that it is been vested will
be better off have a higher return with
the principal reduction modification
versus ain't on an interest only
modification
for someone to take advantage of this
for the moral hazard ratio in other
words i'm going to intentionally default
so i can take advantage of this program
there's a number of roadblocks that
would be there that's in the existing
program and with this first of all they
have to have fire a hardship affidavit
that shows that they're legitimate
reason why they're defaulting they have
to show third party verified third party
income so somebody's going on in
checking this income that would mean
that someone who wants to do this is not
only willing to scrap their credit
history and do that they'd have to be
willing to commit a federal crime by
executing a false affidavit secondly
they would have to the payoff is an
immediate it's over the course of three
years and third they would have to have
such an intimate knowledge of the net
present value test and how it interplays
and the fact that the net present value
test would be more positive for them
with a principal reduction versus a
regular modification now these tests are
not made public their complex I mean
based on I think Jo is work on our work
the servicers themselves have had a
tremendous difficulty implementing them
we're doing an audit just on that
process so i think well there is always
a moral hazard whenever we're giving
benefits to people who basically have
have have been unable or unwilling to
make their required payments i think the
difference between voluntary and
mandatory principal reduction is so
incremental compared to the broader
moral hazard that already exists and i
do think that there are some some pretty
good safeguards and i would say to
treasury if they're willing to go with
us on this and continue to explore this
we'll sit down and brainstorm and try to
come up with some more protections for
moral hazard thank you i'm sure come on
closing comment i think that the
description that you provided is that
what's happening across the states here
in the united states is an accurate one
and it all comes down to an issue of
fairness is it fair to provide a
reduction in a principal payment for one
when another is working very hard to
maintain the mortgage payment that they
have i don't think that we dispute
Treasury for the actions that is taking
to develop a home affordable
modification program for its first Lane
mortgages our view is though that there
are a number of other initiatives that
Treasury has announced but they have yet
to design and implement
including a second lien mortgage program
alternative to foreclosures looking at
underwater borrowers and and our
recommendation is that Treasury urgently
needs to completely design and
implementation of those programs to
provide the relief that's needed in the
market alright thanks and I would just
add the there is an inherent unfairness
in a voluntary program versus mandatory
because the 20 moaners who make their
application to their servicer if it's in
the best interest of the investor and
it's an npv positive they should be
treated the same under voluntary it's
basically up to the discretion of the
servicer and as we know servicers
haven't disincentive to reducing
principal because they're paid on the
outstanding principal balance of their
portfolio so it I think that mandatory
would actually be potentially a much
fairer system than a voluntary one
alright who's chairman you've been very
generous with your time you're more
generous than the other chairman so
thank you for thank you for coming into
chair the end of this say it's hearing
and our witnesses thank you so much all
right then to summarize on that Home
Affordable Modification Program mr.
Hillman why don't you come in on why
many so many bars fail to complete the
trial modification one of the major
reasons why borrowers are not completing
their trial modifications has to do with
the level of documentation that was
required by Treasury initially in the
program in order to get individuals into
these trial modifications quickly they
did not ask for the level of
documentation that is normally
anticipated on income and of other
levels of assets of an individual and as
a result they wouldn't ask for that
information until that they were in the
trial mod and going into a permanent
permanent modification upon checking for
those permanent mods a lot of that
information is shown that they were not
qualified to be included in that program
and therefore had had to exit the
program today the initial modifications
that are being undertaken are requiring
this upfront documentation so you
shouldn't be seeing as
any trial mods not performing as when
the program began and how about in the
hope hotline where many of the advisors
don't have the wherewithal to demand the
transparency of the lenders in the
review process yeah in our last report
we noted that there really was no
effective appeals process for borrowers
interested in appealing the decision
associated with their adjoining in with
the HAMP program and the only available
recourse was the hotline and that
hotline was not aggressively advertised
so that borrowers knew its existence and
we recommended a greater attention being
provided to ensuring that all borrowers
were aware of that possibility either
one of you and we will adjourn this
session and just momentarily we're
getting ready to consider some
legislation that has derisively been
designated as tarp jr. it's about 30
billion dollars that would be
anticipated to expand to three hundred
billion dollars of loans through the
small business jobs bill what do you
think about this capital investment by
the Treasury does it present different
considerations and risks than those of
the capital investments made by tarp I
think one of the concerns and we've
raised this concern letter letter to
this committee is that there is a
potential increased vulnerability to
loss through fraud in the design of this
program I think that that vulnerability
can be addressed by vigorous oversight
we have it's very rare than I look for a
work senator but we've we've advocated
and we believe that it's in the current
form out of the bill we are not granted
oversight authority over over this phone
and I think that would be a mistake the
program is very similar to the tarps
capital purchase program there's some
some differences but it the lessons that
we've learned providing oversight
lessons that have resulted already in
more than five hundred and fifty three
million dollars of savings to the
taxpayer is born from the experience
that we've had in monitoring and
providing oversight to this program the
incentive structure of the program does
leave it open for the potential of
gaming of the system of financial
numbers so that they pay a lower
dividend rate as a result and we do
believe that while this program may have
the ability to do some some very good
and encouraging small business lending
if it doesn't have the proper oversight
they could be it could be could be all
all for all for naught so we will
continue to encourage the Senate as it
considers this bill to to put us and
have us involved in the oversight of the
program have we learned something from
tarp as we approach this small business
lending bill that certain regions of the
country namely an example my state of
Florida week real estate market weak
banks because of bad loans have has tart
had the effect of penalizing those
regions of the country and should we
make the modifications on this small
business lending bill to address them I
mean I do think that some of the goals
of the original goals of tarp to
increase lending were not met and in
part that was because there was
absolutely no incentives or penalties
for banks that don't go out and actually
lend the money and the result is is that
lending has continued to go down since
the original infusion of tarp capital
now Treasury will say and the banks have
told us that that's because that the
reduction would have been even greater
had there not been tarp funding but
there was neither carrots more sticks
with that money I think
this proposed bill of SB LF has some
carrots and has some sticks I don't want
to speak for professor Warren because
she's not here but they put out a report
that looked at the program and
questioned whether the carrots and the
sticks either one of them are sufficient
enough to really compel small business
lending and I think you know I recommend
that portion of her report because I
think it's very informative and has some
other issues that that the congressional
oversight panel has with the structure
of this program Treasury designed its
capital purchase program to treat large
institutions and small institutions on
the same basis that was one of their
premises in the beginning and the idea
there was to provide fairness across all
of our institutions however it is also
the case that the larger institutions
have been able to repay their tarp funds
because they have access to the capital
markets and can therefore through their
shareholders obtain sufficient funds to
repay the tarp program the smaller banks
don't have that same access to the
capital market they're making profits
through lending activities and there's
many local lending issues that are
prohibiting smaller banks from making a
profitable return so the situation for
smaller institutions is different than
the situation for larger institutions
this lending fund that is being debated
within the Senate would provide
additional funding to smaller
institutions similar to what was done
with the capital purchase program with
the intent of enhancing their capital
position to allow them hopefully then to
lend to more small businesses in our
view one of the things that needs to be
considered as part of the debate of this
legislation is the quality of data that
is available to make those decisions as
to whether or not an increase in small
business lending would actually occur or
not
it is difficult to ascertain whether or
not the concerns that we have in today's
small business sector is a supply-side
weakness or a demand-side weakness and
further exploration of what is really
occurring would help inform what the
right decision ought to be thank you
gentlemen for your enlightening
testimony the meeting is adjourned